I have a coach on the line right now
that I'm very very fond of in the second
season as a head coach of the Los
Angeles chargers
Anthony Lin coach how you doing man I'm
doing good there I'm what's going on
coach first and foremost I love you I'm
proud of you and you know what you know
all the reasons why and it's not because
your ethnicity is because you're good
and it was well overdue I appreciate it
man that means a lot
yeah I mean come on man number first in
a MC West at 11 and 3 coming off a
wonderful win versus Kansas City with
the whole country virtually virtually
gave you no chance to win in Casey well
you know it's a common opponent we're
very familiar with them and you know it
was like we liked our chances when we
went in and I just play well on the road
coach they tell me something man what
when you have your finger on the pulse
and you made the decision you go for a
fourth down two-point conversion I mean
what goes into that decision-making
process well you know being on the road
hostile environment and just our whole
mindset was still win the damn game
and I think they were a better
opportunity didn't just do it right then
and there and I went over told cam when
we got the ball back I said when we
score how the two-point play ready
because we're going for two and so I
knew I was going to do that the whole
time and so I don't think anyone was
surprised by it
tell me about your I would love your
quarterback man he's one of my favorites
in the league affiliate members man I
mean he's bald it out right now he's
playing out of control yeah no he's
having an outstanding season the way
he's running this offense and just his
work ethic Deon is it's got to be the
best you know one of the best or the
best I've ever been around
he is very prepared he helped his
teammates and you know he have great
feedback when he comes to sidelines and
I just he's a professional I just I love
the guy man and I'm proud to be his
coach
well it certainly was next man up
because Keenan Allen went down Maggie
Williams stepped up not only didn't step
up he stepped out from amongst the crowd
involved you know it Mike's been doing
that all year you know he's he's healthy
had him fine you know his rookie year it
was still sad to see because he could
tell he was hurting
he was having a lot of fun and you know
so that's why he was gonna feel a lot
but this year is my different stores
from day one know TAS I mean he came in
on a mission and he's been working his
tail off but well Keenan Allen he's been
our number one all year he's done a heck
of a job and so sometimes Mike gets
overlooked but Mike is having
outstanding season don't you came up the
hard way man six seasons in the NFL
undrafted in 92 so you had to work for
every darn thing you've got so how hard
is it to communicate with these to date
players you know you continue to evolve
and grow because you know a lot of today
players know no different in pass or no
african-americans and people just think
because you're you're black you can
communicate relate well that's not the
case breathe out and so you know
football no spike dice told me a long
time ago Dion there football's
relationship business and you just gotta
take the time to get to know your
players understand them and that way you
can get the most out of them and and
also help them you got a guy that I
adore from Florida State University
possibly the Rookie of the Year and he
is like it can cover he could play in
the box he could blitz he does so many
things for you guys tell me about Darren
James when he came on the ground first
of all we couldn't believe it we thought
he'd be gone and we had eyes on our
three technically what we needed him you
know a defensive lineman we so like but
Darren James you know we trusted him
because the teams like Kansas City you
know we needed speed and space guys and
that's that's why we drafted him to beat
that team we just be last week but every
time he's there's no position he can't
play he can play in the box at
linebacker he can play back deep in
middle sill we just around the line of
scrimmage that's a pass rusher at times
but his size speed his range and it's
off the charts and and what I love about
the mostess he loves football I mean you
know the next one why he's wrong I mean
football's been off it's a process
fabrics
before his life you know all along we
but he just has a passion for the game
you know he's always walking around the
building with a football in his hands
he's studying tapes
he just loves football and you got a
bunch of guys like Bo so that that
defense is just playing lights out
they're getting to the ball they're
making plays and those guys seem like
they're having fun and you created that
whole atmosphere it always and they've
done it with a lot of adversity you know
they lost Jason for a days loves cording
legit they lost you know Brendon me bein
for a little while cause you're white
you know that enjoy boys was gone for
most of the season and it's just been
that next man mentality you know next
guy up and and Gus Bradley he's done a
good job of Keane and most of those guys
just put up putting them in positions to
do what they do best and not exposing
people that way so so that's a lot of
that's coaching but those guys man they
just stay play with a lot of heart they
have fun and what I like the most don't
stay on the sidelines they play for each
other go jet when I look at the AFC I'm
thinking about the cheese who you just
be the pagers are not the same team
Pittsburgh's up and down the Texans
you're not only about a year two away
you guys look pretty darn good going
into the playoffs and possibly getting
to Atlanta
well us all year it's been about peaking
at the right time and play our best
football at the right time and and and I
feel like we're starting to come
together and we're getting some guys
healthy and so you know we just we still
have two games left and we gotta take it
one game at a time because you know God
knows my hands are full with Baltimore
this Saturday you know we've been
looking at those two what's the last
three days and it turnarounds in the
league right now they're real option
going back playing red Blake you know me
again man is balding I mean they are
running the lights out of the balls
meter running the ball are your bags
doors they're doing good they do a good
I'd never be out this week it'd be
limited Austin I'm not sure yet but
he'll be back sooner than later
so it'll be nice to get those guys back
out there you know but my young guys
they stuffed up then I'll send the job
coach man I'm proud of you so many
reasons I love you I appreciate you I
love your stab what it represents man
just keep on doing it because you're
opening so many doors that you don't
even understand is your opening just
with your class your dignity your
professionalism and your success I
appreciate you coach Anthony Lee and
head coach out of San B not San Diego
Los Angeles charges I got to get that
out of my spirit Los Angeles charges the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience